straßenwahlkampf in zeiten der pandemie
ist eine einsame angelegenheit wie gern
würde man den wähler umarmen
es geht aber nicht bitter ein
knallharter kampf um die wählergunst in
der provinz gott sei dank gibt es dieses
internet was hat der hund auf dem
skateboard was wie vielen herzlichen hat
er bekommen
befällt 22 22 follower haben sie bei den
ca ich glaube etwas mehr als 1300 ja ich
habe doppelt so viel
ich helfe levin eisenmann von der cdu
und hermine katzenstein von den grünen
segways people bio katzenstein ist in so
aus also wir müssen da schon so ein
bisschen jugendlicher aufbereiten wenn
sie im netz etwas wert wollen
jetzt machen sie auch bei youtube sachen
was was stellen sie bei youtube
ich mache jetzt eine kleine serie
deswegen die demokratie so aus pfarrer
flüster videos erste teil war preisen
zweiter ist schaltung schaltung dritte
ist kette wartung kette und das vierte
ist dann also klappen
hier ist mein social video studio ja wir
haben wir ebenso einfach ein bisschen
professionelle beleuchtung professor
hintergrund eingerichtet das hat jetzt
kein profi niveau das hat meine nichte
aufgenommen mit der handykamera so ja
ein bisschen auf mich nicht sagen die
fünf
ich habe ja auch die aktion dass ich auf
meine wahlplakate meine telefonnummer
gedruckt haben dass man mich erreichen
kannst meine direkte handynummer ach so
es ist natürlich sch laut untersagt
[Gelächter]
schöne städtchen hier
wer zeit mal ein bisschen straßenbahn
gab zu machen da gab es aber nicht
herr katzenstein das bringt nichts was
sie ja immer gut macht ist so den leuten
so darf die zeigen man zu winken
hallo wir sind funktioniert hallo ich
grüße sie ja das ganze nur im netz
hängen und und kein kontakt und hallo
schöne frau wohin geht dann ja was macht
das mit ihnen dass sie endlich mal
wieder einen leibhaftigen abgeordneten
sehen
es ist überwältigend schön aus dem leben
eines politikers um so ein kind auch im
arm zu haben oder zu herzen
jetzt habe ich voll vergessen ja noch
glückskekse glückskekse als give away
das ja auch in die briefkästen machen
können okay ich war schon mal einen auf
besser für hier darum am 14 märz 2021
levin eisenmann wählen supersprung super
kreativ damit in der politik auch mal
gut läuft ist ja auch mal schnell die
kette oder frische der ehrlichkeit
während im wahlkampf maske tragen wenn
man jemanden trifft darf man natürlich
grüßen aber eben nicht klingeln nicht
finger oder dürfen sie aber ich denke
wir sind teufel sonntagnachmittag
elfjährige leute den weg in diesen dank
bei dem schönen wetter
können sie das verstehen ja also
wirklich das ist nicht mehr mein baden
wird die soli variante weil es ja schon
als junger politiker schon aktiv was
könnte er tun in diesen zeiten wo man
wie gesagt als abgeordnete auch ein
bisschen distanz fahren muss sie zu
begeistern für seine partei müsse mehr
bei instagram machen müssen doch sein
aber dass wir gleich eine riesen
überraschung wenn er sich die hose
angezogen hat kommt runter und sie dann
einfach natürlich uhr im club ist der er
seine wahl in sachen verteilen will
hallo abwehr uns sehr gefreut schon
gesehen wisst ihr was ich vom verdacht
habe den habt ihr bezahlt diese reisen
stehen alles von ihr sind
der mit der hose und sowas ist alles gut
um die spannung zu erhöhen da habe ich
später auf erhält er die spannung habt
ihr schon da wo sie mit diesen
erschütternden bildern gebe ich zurück
ins studio wird mehr geld
die leute ich wollte euch nur um ein
kleines auto bieten
einfach anklicken macht's gut
hallo hast du scheiße fährt haye